welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Nick Carmen who is a
partnerships director at a recruitment
business called McDonald & Company and
McDonald's and company are leaders in
real estate recruitment Nick thank you
for joining me
I'd say my pleasure but I'm pretty
nervous not quite sure you have nothing
to be nervous about this has been a long
time coming hasn't it we sort of flow
yeah I suppose I'm a bit of a fanboy and
yeah I think I think what you doing is
brilliant and I think recruitment is
really really short of internal
champions so I think what you're what
you're doing and what what I think it
means people are listen to it I think is
fantastic
no how did you stumble across it out of
interest so I'm pretty late late to
arriving at sort of podcasts is within
the last sort of 12 months say and I
suppose I just got a bit bored of
listening to streaming music and I
thought you know what maybe I can see if
it's the same sort of thing for me
really that more so unlike just
stumbling of course the recruitment
podcast because I had the podcast I
listened to like business mindset all
that sort of stuff and then I just got
bored of one Monday and then I was like
recruitment let's what can I learn about
recruitment
so yeah didn't same I just put it into
in Spotify recruitment and yeah there
wasn't there wasn't a lot yes young guy
with specs what's this guy got yeah when
I looked it yeah was like it's just a
lot of old people talking about
recruitment and I'll see ya as a sort of
young 20 year old I didn't really
resonate do you not I mean
yeah but not honestly absolute pleasure
I think yeah I know we've sort of been
flirting with getting you but since
that's definitely my bag but really
looking forward to diving into your lung
recruitment career cuz you've been in
the game for a while how new hain in the
recruitment industry 13 coming up 14
years 14 years long I find that it
doesn't feel like you look young knife
I'm favorite I don't think that it's
aged you audio aren't we can lie yeah
yes really in the early days
wait in my earliest days we're doing
rector Rex that's probably what really
yeah Wow
okay cool so as you know them we're
always like to start Nick where I'd love
to sort of start this podcast is is yeah
how did you enter the word recruitment
let's start there and we'll go from
there so I left uni in 2004 with a
philosophy degree and just no no idea
what I wanted to do yeah I said I'd gone
I'd gone through all the graduate
recruitment of going to see finance or
law yeah or yeah just I just like an
absolute sheep just followed what all my
mates were doing and went along and
every time I failed at the question why
here what you want to do and I didn't I
didn't get it I didn't understand it and
I had no concept of what what I wanted
to do yeah so I went back home and I
just I picked up a first a first job in
the village I worked an estate agent
near Chester okay cool
I mean I was on 12 grand so the idea of
you know a big house to me was a
prospect and I was doing that I was
doing that for a few months and you know
it was comfortable yeah yeah and my
mates at time so I had the best the best
job ever because yeah it was an office
job but it yeah I was the only one in
the office yeah so if you need a haircut
back then and if I needed a haircut
I'd shut the office and go or a fancy
lunch oh yeah it's just me really yes I
was 21 in a regional estate agency on my
own when they distrusted you straight
out the bastard problem for anyone else
muggins about 8 months and until until
my mate who was a graphic who'd gone to
school do graphic design yeah he'd put
his CV on monster or something like that
yeah looking for graphic design jobs and
all he got were calls about recruitment
saying oh this is just like graphic
design is exactly the same come in have
a chat and he fell for it and he got he
got this job in Manchester with a oil
and gas recruiter and he said me these
guys are Muppets yeah yeah
I think I think the the struck gold of
me but I can't afford the rent if I get
you a job where you go hard with me on
the rent I was like yes Wow sign me up
and so we got me an interview the net
the next day I went along to the first
stage and I thought it was amazing I had
this is what I'm fascinated about now is
that what people might know about the
criminal what they might think about
they know about recruitment because back
then I didn't I didn't know there was
any industry that was like this hmm and
so after that after that first interview
I went back home and started you know
sort of got out googling you know what
is recruitment and tried to learn a bit
about it and at the time I thought I was
applying for other recruitment jobs and
what happened was not very clear is it I
can't remember the name but it does this
there was a green and black rector wreck
who had sent my CV through looking for
all the industries I thought I wanted to
go work for so I was looking to go into
marketing recruitment or finance or
legal recruitment I got I got this
cornice this guy from London I was in
Chester just said yeah we know this
market really really well definitely
we've got it nailed and he set me up
with out six interviews the very next
day and I got through to the third the
third interview during that day and I
got a call from the other guy saying are
you are you free now if so you can come
in are RMDs free this afternoon and
interest to meet you so that's like I'm
not enjoying this interview lark and I
think I'd come out of an interview with
computer futures whereby I've been sat
across this table with this guy who just
kept thrust in his Rolex in my face and
I think he used he used a phrase that
weird a sort of business that if you're
afraid to get your bollocks on the table
and say look at this we're not for you
[Laughter]
you know you're at your bangle and you
are not for me and so I saw a call at
the rectory house and really soon at me
but I'm gonna I'm gonna cover this other
one yeah but don't worry and yet don't
worry because I think they're recruiting
and I thought at the time I was really
helping him out and telling the rep
direct that there might be a vacancy and
obviously the time he must have thought
yeah so whoever that is I don't if that
guy remembered not my I'm really sorry
and that so then that was what Madeline
no no no that was yeah he's doing Oscar
right yes sir
so to be really so I am a massive fan of
the I think it's about sort of 18 months
I spent with Oscar associates but it's a
after shortly after I left the whole
business had you know went through a
huge change and it's and it's I think
it's I think it's now a really really
success yeah it's great online but it's
that's not that's not the same
individuals I was I was working for so
my story is quite quite different I just
went oh yeah yeah that's fair enough so
and then we saw what market did you end
up in so they were in oil and gas IT and
Rettig wreck oh really
and so they the wreck to wreck lame is
called Maggie Epstein and if you're in
Manchester and you know wonderful things
she's first right and she she she
interviewed me for the business and said
right yeah I think we're gonna get on
really well you know would you fancy
coming to work for me yeah and I get it
you have no idea or Rex records great
great let's do it yeah let's do that and
and I did I I'm incredibly grateful for
like the opportunity as those guys gave
me yeah but it was Wild West
rhetoric 18 months of rectory it's not
it was not the market that I think I
learned the most about it was it was the
people I worked with and for really
because it was it back then it was it
was run by a guy who was a next sales
trainer yeah so he would know he'd done
his hard graft in in the eighties yeah
and you know he'd got some really clear
views on what sales is no it's worked
and so my first day you're given a
script even a full folder so I'm doing
it with my hands now it's probably I
said work about six or seven centimeters
deep this folder on every circumstance
it's ever going to come up you've got a
script how to answer it Wow and your
your job was every night was to read you
know read a new circumstance learn it
and then we had every Wednesday and
Friday mornings 8 o'clock were run
through role plays yeah and every one
hole ever hollow no matter how
experienced you are every one role
played and
that was that was fantastic to learn a
bit about the science of recruitment I
think I think sort of I probably got
slightly different views use now but
that that instilled in me a huge amount
of discipline I think that's tough how
to do it and when we weren't role
playing we played this game in the
morning called articulate this so this
is a this is a like a card game whereby
you're giving notes to people playing it
you got card in front of you and it's
got a word on it which you cannot say
but you've got to get the other person
to guess what that word is you've got to
describe it without using that word or
five other words that are similar to it
and the idea is the plate you play this
game for to get your your brain in gear
in the morning to get you up and going
and ready to start talking people
straightaway yeah and these guys had
played this this game so often and for
so long that they'd just burnt out all
the cards and the MD now wrote his own
cards every day to get people thinking
about it keep it challenging yeah so
like super discipline like super super
competitive I mean this this thing would
this would get really heated with it
really heated and it was but it was it
was great you know it got it got an
amazing energy and buzz to what were my
peers were all really early twenties ya
know when I think back I was looking up
to our biggest billows were probably 25
years old
really the only catch what you know what
back then I thought they were absolutely
minted really yeah because they had a
new Volkswagen in all because they had a
house or yeah and so and I listen this
is a 2004 2004 right she doesn't know it
we've been 2005 to 2006 yeah cool
so that lot I'd be really keen just to
let some thanks for that so let let's
dig into sort of the majority of courage
and McDonald and company right so so you
join with the London company after that
obviously experience and just a sort of
layer out then what's what's been your
sort of courage and within that business
because I know we were just saying
before that
yeah the typical route right is like
join as a consultant then you become a
man
some point director whatever so you're
now a partnership director yeah yeah so
let's just frame out for people so
initially yeah I'd done my sort of 1218
month stint Oscars doing rhetoric and
yeah I think what I the good thing was I
learned that I really enjoyed it yeah
and but in in that environment there was
bits I didn't like for example are terms
conditions were forty percent forty four
zero
the game was don't mention terms and
conditions so so that hopefully you know
someone when I couldn't yeah he wouldn't
see it and then we just would just
invoice him and it so it it was there
was lots of fantastic things I learned
about urgency yeah
there was no database there was no
debate there was no database so I flew
every Mart everyone's dead on paper CVS
and job boards and your your job every
morning was to call up the candidates
say right you're on your board you term
a horror story about someone being on a
job board and you had to get them off
the job board within 30 minutes because
if they've stayed on after 30 min ago
they were Guardian see it so the idea
was you know that whole that whole desk
lasted about a week
if you hadn't place that person you
spoke to on Monday by Friday no good
yeah start again yeah so the there's
bits of that I enjoyed I took away from
there's other bits I didn't so I made it
a lot if I'm gonna do this I wanna make
a career out of it I don't think I can
do it here but there must be other
places I can go and learn about so I was
wreck to wreck so I suspect myself out
nice and I met these alongside a few as
I'm at these guys called McDonald &
Company who who were just a bit older
than I was
no they wore and they wore a smarter
suit than I did and you know they told
they told a good story about sort of how
people have built careers internally
what they got involved in and I just I
just I liked it a lot yeah so you joined
them I joined that so I joined them on a
Thursday I flew out to LA baya Thursday
afternoon for their company conference
for four days and that's my first my
first day that's when I met everyone
barbarian review have one of those
horror stories where Monday is like oh
my god
that was all right with you right yeah
yeah yeah they're bad there so okay cool
so no you were saying before so you said
you said before so 10 years you spend
like solely billing Fiona and then you
spend two years as a manager but what
was such a frame-up so though I get
there yeah so what was the sue Bennett
word on the company for how many years
well yes twelve years so was it the
first ten yeah roughly speaking so when
I joined it so I joined in 2006 as my
job then was a contract recruited in
Manchester but doing a London market
okay and I work with an established
contract biller then and my job was
right so yeah probably what he's doing
but I apply it to a different a
different market yeah I never done
contract before but he was a greeter
who's he was great he was great training
loads of patience and I learned I
learned a lot a lot from him and I had
two years where I thought were we're
exceptionally sort of successful and I
was really proud of it and then when I
didn't win big sorry Best Newcomer I was
furious
yeah gutted furious at a massive sort of
chip on my shoulder saying right I'm
gonna I'm gonna prove them wrong yeah
and yeah I think in some ways I think
that's a lot of that is what I look back
into sort of motivates me yeah okay so
it didn't win that but you when you
start in contract I didn't get in top
five really yeah so you know whatever I
thought I was doing not yeah those guys
didn't agree yeah well so then so the
first two years and then what do you do
for the next said it's a yes before your
time so this that was in 2008 yeah and
so I I didn't get it at a time but then
when you start seeing on the news about
banks falling apart people leaving with
their everything it's all there it's
their stuff in boxes is this or economic
crisis and I did I thought well that's
alright Lehman Brothers isn't one of my
clients so I'll be I'll be cool you'll
be alright and we weren't what market do
you agree and so this is this is so this
is real estate I was doing contract work
and that was probably the the most
unpopular type of recruitment of time
because contract staff are very very
obvious everyone knows your contract
everyone knows you're they're paid a
premium to be there you're not you're
not
terms as permanent please the Clanton's
cluster don't you exactly did it they
don't ease make you redundant they just
say thanks very much don't come in on
Monday and so I had yeah in fact three
years of a really cold miserable winter
I've just hardly any any activity so the
treatment my second year I'd build 256
yeah and then those next three years I
was building a roundabout of about a
hundred and ten to about 130 well I
thought I thought my world had caved in
yeah and that was all contrast there
that's all contract in many ways
contract as much less it was unpopular
having some something happen every month
because these guys were still some of
these guys are still turning in saved me
the most the guys doing perm would then
blanking for two three four months at a
time
wow you know it's really really hard
graft I remember it won't the lowest
point I didn't book an interview no no
one went for an interview for 16 weeks
whoa
and oh my god what how do you know why
what am I doing wrong and the markets
changed a bit you know the Styles have
changed you know back back then our
biggest marketing tool was mailshots
yeah and I remember stares pinned up in
our Manchester office as a reminder to
me but there's a I the biggest challenge
we had then was what do you name your
mail shot and this and this is in sort
of September so it been about sort of 12
months of economic crisis now remember I
thought I've nailed this recruitment
freeze begins to thaw because I dad I
don't know I booked an interview so I
thought yet there at the end of that
yeah I was looking and it wasn't oh yeah
I did another two years of really really
hard really you had to go out do their
own right so let let us hold here for a
second and I think again thinking about
people listening the staff let's start
there then like how why didn't you quit
why didn't I quit
still feels quite a long time ago so
he's yes it's like distant yeah
thankfully maybe because it's so
miserable you've put it it's memories
but I think ultimately you're in you're
in that moment if someone said it's
gonna last three three years maybe I
maybe I might have yeah but right now
you're just constantly thinking it's
just around the corner and one call away
I'm just one call away you know from
from getting 16 weeks and I'm interview
that that requires a lot
resilience because you know that's
typically the Brahmin sort of know
someone could drop this mark blah blah
blah you're not that you're not even
getting that not even getting a sniff
yeah it's nothing you get you get people
sort of laughing at you people crying
because they'd just be made redundant
you're trying to market them yeah it's
really hard graft but but you don't you
haven't got that perspective hindsight
that none time you've just you've just
got to keep doing because you know the
best really fortunately the business
supported everyone you know we made we
did make some redundancies but a real
minimum number of redundant sees no one
said right now we know we've got some
old players the owners of our business
are you know are older than I am
they've seen previous recessions and
they were really visible and all the
offices saying yeah we've been here
before it's gonna be really hard graft
but you just keep doing the basics and I
know you'll get the way through and it
and we bought into that mmm but into
that unfortunately I just bought my
first apartment and you know I had quite
a bit of debt so you know maybe some of
that sort of played up quite a big part
that's why why I have to do it yeah so
because I guess that's interesting then
let's let's bring that to sort of
current times now there's a lot of
people saying obviously there's
definitely recession around the corner
and things like that like what from your
own experience there then and it going
through that how do you think that then
helps you prepare for what what could be
a really tough time or a challenging
time in your market you I'm in it so
maybe a maybe I'm sort of I'm Jim Lee an
optimist but but i but i equal it back
of mine i know that you know this this
could all end tomorrow there's the I try
not to read too much of economic press
but know they'll tell you when you're in
the biggest or the longest ball mark we
have ever had with a recession has to
happen soon according to their cycles
yeah and so yeah the best bit of advice
I could give to anyone internally or
externally is the things that keep you
going are those client relationship that
wasn't my thing and you've got you've
got it you've got to think think about
right who who knows me really well who
trusts me to do to do the job properly
and if you haven't got that relationship
you are extremely extremely fragile
ground mmm because I think that was
gonna be my thing and I had to chat pond
he was at the love of an actually toning
he said that he went through that period
as well and that was something that he
said it was like look when the recession
happens
maybe a lot less people that you can
turn around to but you need to have
people you can turn around to clients
that are willing to give your business
so I wouldn't help you out and there
again it comes to relationships doesn't
at the end of the day like what what
relationships do you have that you can
actually count on them and rely on it's
really easy to think about the
relationships with clients and
candidates been quite disposable yeah
there's lots of them lots of work to go
after you know if that one doesn't work
out for enough are doing it but but in a
market where they're really rare they're
incredibly valued so in hindsight then
is it so I know you said during that
tough period you're doing the basic it's
focusing on that but was you doubling
down on relationships or like did you
naturally was you naturally doing that
or was it just trying to get one call
away trying to make stuff happen no it's
two years in a no one knowing you were a
warrior so my my job was like sort of
trying to steal other people's
relationships no it's calling I think
yeah I know you've worked with the
competitor for this long yeah I know
they might you know there might have
been certain year to your son's
christening but I'll try a bit harder
and yeah sometimes that works well as it
works so first five years contract then
and then how long did you do contracts
for I was in contract and that
definitely got me through a really dark
dark period and and then an opportunity
came up so I was in the Manchester
office doing a London desk yeah but in
our London office a member of the motor
stuff was going on her first into
maternity and she she ran the perm
division equivalent to what I was doing
contract and was that Marcus so this is
in real estate it was it was doing what
was called technical so it's project
managers yeah okay and she was going to
mattli she had two young women as the
staff and they said right yeah you've
got as much experience as anyone else
would you know would you like to come
down move to London and then take up the
management responsibilities and then
when Christine comes comes back and
we'll just you know we'll see where
we're at and it was in some ways I'm
incredibly grateful for like the
opportunity but it was just awful timing
for me mmm I met my girlfriend who no
late stood out to me my wife at bought
an apartment and we were pretty settled
in the north so what I thought has been
really clever with as I said old you
know one I try and do this part-time no
I live in Manchester I'll go to
Manchester three days a week and I'll
travel down to London two days a week
and let's see how that goes and I think
there probably Krishna mobi
anyone better to do it they said yes and
that's that's how its work now for eight
years
really yeah okay eight years eight and
then so you've done perm for eight years
so yeah and that's see I never looked
back then
so oh yeah and how was that transition
initially how was there any challenges
there so learning so cuz a lot of people
a lot of people have spoken to you when
they hear contract builders they're like
oh love of fifteen fifteen like crazy
numbers right it's a light on getting
the contract or do you not I mean
so how did cuz you done the reverse
riots with contractor perm how how did
you find that
I think it's anyone listening there is
the the rules of engagement for contract
and perm are different okay contract is
really high
urgency yeah the reason someone was
choosing to hire someone a contract
basis is because they are they can't do
on a permanent basis or it's not
suitable so they're in this moment and
yeah that's you've you've got to get
yourself in in that moment with these
clients and solve it you need that
resource as quickly as possible really
quickly and so in some days they'll be
flexible as to the skill about sit yeah
and permanent is quite different
permanent and people think is much much
longer-term when people when people are
choosing to hire people they see these
people being there five ten years down
yeah so their expectations are very very
different
so what I'd say is anyone who sat on
their desk now where they do contractor
perm go sit next to someone who does a
different sector to you so if your
contract goes to next n1 it does permit
if your perm go sinister in contract
because there are lessons that both of
you can learn from that mmm tonight so
there was a lot was the lessons of young
quite early on there so because I think
my my early days working without a
database and that really speediness and
then doing contract you know I think I
always had real agents really ill to see
that if I found a client who wanted
something from me they got it that day
you know it didn't matter what you know
what time of day it was you know I'd
make sure they got they got that from me
because that was really important me and
when I moved to to a new market doing
doing perm that was really important
about that I built on I built on that
because no one knew who I was and no one
had any loyalty towards towards me so I
had to build build that up not to try
and build it up really really quickly
mmm and there's two there's two guys
there who would he
were doing it for but they're probably
about maybe they've sort of six to
twelve months since they were still
pretty green so between us and here we
have to get to work it out together how
we're going to do really so so just so
your role then at that point so you as
managing these people straightaway yeah
really
how difficult was that that was really
different ever managed anyone before
right I never managed any one hand on
the desk and I was only there two days a
week so it's probably not a surprise it
didn't go very well what did you learn
that what do you learn what should I
learn well go into it later but probably
probably not enough because I've I
repeated some most mistakes later I
laugh but what I suppose I did learn is
it's it's it's really really difficult I
think now manage know manage just
managing the billa near the billing
thing I think I was reasonably
comfortable with mmm but management is
so much harder and you know looking back
I bet out and I was an ass to manage to
manage you know I thought I knew
everything unless unless I saw you as
being the absolute pinnacle I thought
what do they know and I can so I can
solve as myself yeah and when people did
that to me furious but it I didn't know
how to how to how to get them round that
yeah and so in many ways I just I said
those guys do you know what if you do it
let's get let's let's all go learn our
mistakes sort of separately you go do
what you do you know have no forget
about the client you take you take you
take all that and I'll go see if that's
go see if I can find it and let's have a
bit of internal competition to see how
that goes because I in many ways that's
what I
I enjoyed the company competitive bit
I've always enjoyed really yeah I don't
think they did but I enjoyed it really
so so just to help me understand and
then we'll dive into a couple of things
so so from that moment then you've
always worked the same niche and
important sit yes since that has been
some as markets moved to adapt but yeah
so then how long did you manage those
people before you then ended up just in
the back yeah Hannah member for about
nine months nine months really and then
and then the period and then what in the
newer then what just said what happened
was is that sort of after after nine
months we were still really struggling
with
to fight to find our feet the good thing
was I think I'd I'd learned a lot about
that market by that by that time but
they needed more time than I had I was
there two days a week while still you
know it's still sort of studying myself
learning what this was so what we did is
we just we took my team of three
including me and we just plugged it into
another team and we had a more
experienced manager Weber I just became
a starting more experienced consultant
under there waiting focused on yourself
and your own perform and then yeah so
that's very very grateful to them to say
right now these guys your problem now
yeah you can crack on yeah and I'm sure
they were delighted by that as well and
then how and then how long was you then
just focusing on your own Billings and
so so then so I had the same manager
then for probably about four or five
years yeah she was just focusing on
doing what you do back yeah I was yeah
that's a then the only challenge I had
then was you know it's where's each fee
coming from and that suited me really
really well oh and focus on yeah that's
all like to focus on you make it sound
easy but no but yeah so okay it's just
for me to understand okay great so be
interesting to get your thoughts on this
also we were talking earlier and I'm
saying about so I know that you went
into that role in that position where
someone had already been working and
they went on mat leave you said so like
but as you said no II not had any
loyalty to you
so I guess what's been your journey from
that period in terms of building up with
they're splitting up the relationships
how have you approached that as I said
the business of element these types of
things is something that people always
talk about this difficult they struggle
with what's been your experience and
journey with building client
relationships and these lots of things
so I could wax lyrical business time
because this this is the piece I enjoy
the most
really and the people the people in
certain dealing with sort of internal
people is my biggest challenge and
problem is my steepest and incomplete
learnings curve whereas business moment
I feel most comfortable with hmm and I
think it
I was listened to one of your earlier
podcast and someone said something that
really sort of hit home to me and it's
you've got to love what other people
hate doing yeah it'll be really
successful at something you've got it
you've got it you can't just do the same
as everyone else and so for me that's
that's definitely that business
development piece and I think what
when I'm speaking to people internally
it's that the sooner you realized that
business development is at the core of
everything you do it will change the way
you look at it hmm
as soon as you stop thinking that you
can business development is a it's a
piece of what I do and so I will I will
put it into my weekly plan and drip it
in these hours and not think about it
until those hours you're always going to
struggle because you're always going to
find it really difficult you're gonna
find it so challenging to to turn to
change from candidate care to certainly
attracting new clients so how did you
integrate then how did you how did you
integrate it to your week then for it to
not feel like that so I think it becomes
then a part of every action you do in
recruitment so every time you're if
you're if you're on the phone to it to a
candidate you're not just qualifying
that candidate for for the job they
might be most suitable about now you're
asking the questions about what else
might they be what they know who do they
work with who they worked with before
what can they help you out you know
being really frank and honest with them
saying what you want to get get out from
it I've always found really really
valuable in being honest with them about
saying this either this is something I
don't know about can you help me out
with it or this is what I want to this
who I want to go work with can you help
me out with it and has been really
valuable but then also with with with
doing not only sort of the candidates
but even when you're when you think
you're winning a business firm you've
just you've just got a job if if your
focus and sunny turns off from won't you
have got a job I'm gonna fill that fill
that job you're into this sort of a
stop-start cycle mmm so the the the way
in which I think to look at it is by by
accepting that business development is
something you have to do every second of
the day you start thinking about right
this job now what doors has that don't
unlock for me else be there and suddenly
then you get a job and then you start
thinking right why where else can I get
that next job from how do i how do I
make sure that the five cannabis I put
forward to that job how do I find out
that I can then put those five calots
the five jobs because then I've got five
placements not just one and four and
four that's really resonated with me
actually because I think if I think
about when I was in recruitment your so
write it you'll you can also that it
will
like build up like build up unnecessary
pressure as well when you like because
what we did was we did our best business
development 10 to 12 every Tuesday and
Thursday whatever yeah you're totally
right that's it we're really ready so
twelve eleven fifty-nine you know you're
thinking right I've got to get my
business development suit on now put my
tin hat on and I'm gonna make daddy
you're so right to someone and say right
I'm he Shem this is what I'm doing best
you know you've got yeah your features
and benefits written down you're telling
them all about why you're amazing and
someone shuts the door on you and
suddenly you think laughs I failed yeah
sure what if you do it every day you
know every minute of the day every
action you're taking and it's part of it
you you will accelerate you'll get
better you'll get better that but more
important you'll be far more successful
at it yeah no I think that it sounds
really simple and basic but that that
really is a really acute mindset change
that no it no we don't do just business
development win this period it's like
it's every single second and it's it's
that it's the might having that mindset
isn't it because you do go into you are
definitely a hundred percent going in
when you're the candidate stuff you that
becomes very comfortable very quickly
when you have to have those
conversations and yeah you're totally
right so how is that how has that
impacted your performance and so does
that enable you then to expand accounts
make more out of just potentially that
someone could have just gone yep thank
you for that job bomb done there's like
I can make that placement now how how
have you found having that mindset
changes definitely I feel like that
could unlock a lot of things for people
how is that impacted so what and so so I
suppose the big the biggest change is
it's meant that I've been I think I've
been more agile in the markets I've
worked so by having it as part of my
stuff every every part of day I think
I've been able to pick up on what's
what's movements of what changed in the
market much much quicker hmm and so what
so my knee backs those days when I had
to first move those deaths and then the
market the guys who I was working with
two guys I said well yeah right we've
got an established client list you guys
split that 50/50
you know I cuz I thought I thought maybe
they don't make them like me more I say
I'm not going to take anything off you
you have everything there that
everyone's we've we've taken three
people's client lists and just turn it
to two I'll go try and find something
else and that that helped me
Rio's really quickly that actually their
client list was [ __ ] and and actually
there was an area that we didn't we
didn't realize I didn't work at all and
it was it was it was there to there to
be taken by by my my thing I think that
I'd I still do today that it's probably
one of my best tactics is yeah once I
once I've got a job on I don't go start
looking for candidates the first thing I
do is I'll then bring ten clients and
say I've got this job on this is the
skills this is who it's with and this is
then this is what it's pain who would
you recommend for it and in that that
afternoon when I call this ten clients
by the end of it not only well I have
their recommendations so who the very
best people on the market to do that but
I've also told them what I'm doing in
the market I'm a specialist in that's
that's often if I've picked them really
well they're competitors and so these
guys thinking oh I need that that's
smart simple really simple but know you
again I'm thinking yeah if you call ten
clients particularly if to particularly
if it's a role which you know businesses
are always at some point looking for
during their business journey or
whatever because again if I think of my
insurance days a particular job title if
you had you always hit it and cream like
if you had ten other I've had ten and my
date is commercial can't happen if you
had ten commercial cameras off and
Morton not you know two or three of
those guys will you know we'll say Joe
Vuli oh if only if only I knew someone
like that on you up brilliant well I
know I know hoots Courtney's my next
call yeah I feel I find one person for
it exactly and that's and that's then
that's how that sort of that the way in
which I've sort of tried to focus around
sort of efficiencies is that
yeah then I've got and I've got my
client who's looking for this I said I
work hard I deliver I deliver those
those five candidates but I take those
five candidates then to the next two
three or sometimes I might send them to
all ten and just saying oh I've interest
you might have a quick look over these
guys and see if I'm on the right track
mmm simple but I really like that so
really quick and have you always source
for your job done I think do I do it
yeah how does that mean or
clearly or someone that's really
comfortable the business development
contra good at it like a view yeah if it
was a view
than yourself of you had support how's
that it's probably changed over time has
that say I still probably even even now
I probably self deliver quite a high
proportion of the work I wear now in
many ways it's because I know I can do
it quickly quickly using just using that
same process really but inevitably the
more work you win the less the less time
you've got to deliver it so yeah there's
lots of great people I work with who are
fantastic how what's been your
experience in juggling that then cuz
clearly be a you've got some great tax
that's around that some great practical
advice and then you have you have you
then you have you always been someone
that's been able to find these kind of
dates and quiet you know I'm in sure
answer is yes it's not not because I've
got you know any sort of like sort of
special tricks it's because if I've told
someone I'll go and do it
I've grown the dirt yeah if the if I if
I make one no one bad promise I can't
call them again yeah so II went 20 yeah
do I find you find it easy no of course
not and certain sometimes you know I get
myself really stuck we're probably
promised someone that I'm gonna do it
and I ring 10 people and everyone goes
they don't exist yes and then yeah then
I'm how so then so then okay cool so in
terms of I really I think that such
practical advice I actually love that I
hope a lot of people can get sort of
real value from that how and then how
what's in a sort of whole perm journey
then what's been the sort of performance
because obviously what what you shared
with me we was dive into figures and
stuff what so how have you done billions
wise and how has that been over the last
four eight years so last year I build
for 75 and I managed a team for four
people and that's per night Jack that
good figures yeah really good I just
feel like I just I don't know there's
big pop me that I feel like big part of
that is definitely really known in that
client piece and having that mindset
that you were talking about so how long
have you managed that team for so I
managed at most that's in so much to my
second incarnation of Management
after the first time I gave you know I
gave it back for sort of three or four
years and I thought and then and then I
took it back not not being there being
really brutally honest not because I
wanted to manage people but because I'd
got I'd spent sort of what it must have
been eight years at the same company and
I would I was the I was the top biller
in the UK at that time but I wasn't
allowed in the management meetings it
wasn't a manager and that used to really
great on me that there were decisions
being made that I couldn't I couldn't
get involved in and it really and I
really wanted to and so when I raised it
this is well you know manager right how
hard can it be
and I just forgot everything that I had
all the struggles that had previously
and thought yeah let's do it
and so I spun out of that established
team and I just took my desk and and
then at that time split it into three I
we recruited two people really that's
two years ago how and then so what's
been your best year then if you've been
to oh yeah I've been at this so long I
almost almost
well I will answer that cuz it's almost
irrelevant in a sense is this I hear
loads people who come up with some
massive numbers but it's like in the two
thousands and your listeners probably
don't care about I deleted that so
firstly doing that last year with a team
I think night that is amazing I think
again I didn't it didn't come without
sacrifices course well into what in
terms of probably management so so
you're better so yes of what your bill
is dropped a bit so I do so know so in
the two two years to the first that
first year I remember really thinking
that right right I've gone now I've have
I think I've internally I've got to I've
got a certain reputation then fourth of
what what I can do and I was like my
first year in management I what I also
want to succeed yeah
because suddenly I was in this as
although I'd gone from being this
biggest biller to being in the
management team but suddenly I was but
with ask the smallest team so I'd gone
from like sort of big fish there
overnight by somehow asking for it
and and I didn't I just didn't sit very
well with me I felt I didn't I didn't
like it so I thought okay well I'm gonna
I'm gonna show these guys how I did it
so we brought in two people and I had
the strategy I'm still only doing
part-time I'm still only in Linda's
office two days a week and so I couldn't
take on two completely fresh fresh grads
so we took two people with some life
experience but a minimum amount of
recruitment experience and I thought I
thought you're not first-time
recruitment didn't go very well so maybe
because I was too competitive maybe I
asked too much I've been a manager yeah
so I'm gonna be really generous and I'm
gonna so I just took my desk and I said
right if you do one deal I'll give you
an account okay and so yeah roughly
speaking I think sort of you operate
with about ten clients any one time yeah
and so each deal they did the night the
night then I gave I gave them one and
[Music]
during that two at 12 months I was just
constantly conflicted she's never I was
just never happy and well because what
happened was is that these these things
I'd worked really really hard to achieve
and build up these relationships not so
much that because I think yeah i in my
mind I thought you know I'm gonna want
these guys to like me and if I give them
this they're gonna like me but actually
because you went yeah whenever
inevitably there's no there's no no
christum those guys but when you're
given something you never treats it
they're the same way as when you've had
an angry Mars and these guys are
probably asking way too much them as
well cuz these are quite complex
relationships and areas to manage and
they didn't do it as well as I thought I
might have done but you've got to make
the mistakes haven't you I kept dipping
in and pointing out where I thought they
were going wrong they're gonna yeah
we're gonna really great on each other
but I I was conflicted because there
were things I wanted to go and do that I
couldn't because it was at the it was at
the expense of spending time with those
guys and I thought I'm only here two
days a week so I can't
I've got to give them those you know
dose two full days otherwise it's just
not fair and so what happened in that
first sort of twelve months was that I
spent my time when I was faced time with
them managing their
and given you everything I could to try
and make them as as good as they could
be
yeah and then the other three days a
week when I wasn't with them I tried to
fit in a five-day billing week and it
meant it meant that I'd work my weekends
and my evenings and it was it was really
hard graft and the end of it what
happened was that I build 250k and weed
at the end of the year we had this
massive sort of party because that team
then had won five at the six awards or
our internal Awards it won biggest
biller Best Newcomer best deal and as
your team yeah that was my team
sometimes I forget what it was and that
and the one we came second in was sort
of highest revenue per head so it we had
paper yeah a great year they were
supportive but I felt really
disappointed because it was things I
left on the table that I really wanted
to go and achieve in that year mMmmm and
so the next year I thought well okay
fine we're gonna I'm not giving up and
I'm not giving up a manager I don't want
people to think I've failed this so what
I maybe needs to do maybe just need to
recruit a few more people and we need to
build a bit more of an a steady nucleus
in this internal esteem yeah and then it
can be be sort of this ideas they can
bounce off each other as well and they
can then sort of learn collectively but
actually that didn't work very well at
all as he's probably it's probably
people listening you idiot and it meant
there was more management time and so
the own the only the only way I found to
balance that was that I became a lot
more selfish of my time when whereas in
when you was on your free day yeah yeah
so I couldn't I couldn't up I couldn't
spend any more time doing my personal
billing so it meant I'd eat eight into
them their management time and I did
more of what I did and and so that's and
so the good thing from was that that
returned me back then to my billing
habits and what I would I enjoyed but it
was at the expense then of how that team
develops no doubt really yeah so would
you go if you were to start that process
again and how would you do it
differently if you were to start that
first year again you wanted to get into
those management meetings how do you
approach it differently I probably may
be clearly still working out yeah of
course doesn't everyone yeah
I probably would have been a bit a bit
more forceful with the leadership send
that just don't call it management team
then what in terms of like getting
involved yeah yeah yeah if I think I've
got something to add but I'm not because
I'm I'm a sort of a successful biller
don't don't block that door because I
haven't got a management badge yeah so I
met Nick maybe yeah it's not something
I've thought about too much interesting
but that's that's probably what I could
be a lot of people that may feel like
that yeah so what near the long story
short is it's at the end of that two
years this going back going back then
what happened was I recruited two people
so two great managers previously
management experience one person run a
business is the person that would run
some really big teams and I gave them
the team and they those guys now run its
co-heads mmm interesting management's
hard isn't that it's a it's so much
harder than I ever thought and and Joe
if people are listening to this and
they've continued to listen about the
one thing I would I would really
recommend is that just management is so
difficult and if you haven't done it
before you may be just so just you know
shouldn't mean just find something
they're really good at and just tell him
and just give him a bit of praise and
say thank you they'll they will really
really appreciate that cuz yeah it's
dark and it's lonely and it's miserable
[Laughter]
so how how so what I really like to sort
of dive into now sheds some of these
things but I think honestly I think if I
think the conversations I have on a
daily weekly basis for people around
performance and things like that I don't
know be really hung up on the Billings
but I think it's just part of it is a
good indicator but I have weekly
conversations with people hisham I'm
really struggling to break the 200k mark
light and and progressing to go I mean
some people can really plateau so like
how viewers push forwards clearly or
someone the super-competitive
willing to put in the work clearly but
like what do you think of some of the
things that really contributed because
that that honestly again I think that
that's not really impressive like if
there may be a lot of your thing that
how how how can you do those sort of
numbers in today's market I think back
to sort when I shared what what what are
what make what are the sort of typical
good Billings in today's market people
had different opinions but if so if you
were something that's billing 200 K plus
like you've seen as a really good biller
yes 250 def that's not mean for people
to listen and feed to go yeah I did
before under Simon last month that in
perm that is mean it's all I guess I'd
love to just sort of if there's anything
else in there like what do you think is
it really enable you to do that and
achieve that because there'll be a lot
of people think that it's just so out or
grow out of out of their planet do you
know I mean and Arthur if I was
listening I'd be like how how has he
done that I think that I think the thing
to remember is when I when we might have
a conversation with someone about sort
of you know right I've hit I've hit my
my pinnacle yeah and it's and if it's
not as high as that as maybe whereas
ours
I was billing if as soon as we start
having a chat most people sort of forget
about the basics and just cover it in
covering their bases because you get a
bit comfortable or you get a routine and
maybe over time you've adapted it to
suit to suit who you are you know but
actually a revisiting some of the basics
about sort of about sort of how you
might sort of manage your candidates how
you might manage those clients how you
sort of prefect the processes that go
through and and crucially that you never
forget the business development is a
part of every part of part of the job
you do and you're you're saying you'll
start then to seed there are gaps that
you can you can really tweak and that's
that's always almost it's minor tweaks
yeah that will make another way yeah a
big in fact but the other thing is you
know I'm the self when I'm sorry I'm
just the same when I write it sort of
berries have say 250 or 300 or sort of
350 and more often than what was
happening was that I I was approaching
closer and closer to sort of the sort of
pinnacles of where of the people who I
saw might women PS yeah and I thought
well if they're doing 275 if I'm doing
250 I'm doing all right
because 275 the ceiling and then someone
would come along and do 300 yeah oh so
it was a 10 yeah
sudden suddenly your whole your whole
perspective changes about what you know
what you can do and then so if you're if
you're engaged without a big impact it
has massive impact even and to this day
now so so I've so at my peak I spent
three years as UK top billet and two
years as global top biller but now I
wouldn't I wouldn't make it we've got
we've got million-pound billers now and
I think how'd you do that
yeah and so learning you know learning
sort of constantly thinking that
actually what I'm doing there is people
find more time in the day to do more I
think that so if you're in an
organization now about if you have sort
of you've reached this at a plateau and
you'll think you're maxed out and if you
are the biggest Bologna are at 200 or
225 you know you're doing a really good
job but there is definitely things you
can do to increase in so it's not
someone in your business who you can
chase after go and find it nope speak to
you yeah recruitment networks like style
events find someone who's doing it it's
amazing how much of an impact that has
like because all of a sudden it's like
Nick this is real oh there's more I
didn't want you know what on it and I
think the there's a bit more so I think
it's a lot more enjoyable might the
years where when I was chasing other
people were much more enjoyable than
when I was in that top seat because be
and I've used it a few soon as you load
and I should say I'm not a cyclist I'm
not entirely sure if this is true but
you know like in they they call a group
cyclists at peloton don't they yeah
there's there's someone at the first
space and everyone else is drafting
behind them so they're so they're you
know in this pack just behind them being
in that pack contantly having someone to
focus on and chase after is so much
easier than when you're out at the front
because when I was out at the front it's
really lonely and mentally it's
incredibly draining having this massive
fear what if I drop yeah you have that
massive expectation on yourself I don't
know if I'm unique or not but when i but
yeah expectation when I was number one I
put so much value on that
that was my reputation that's what yeah
people thought about me that I thought
well from not what am I mmm sudden you
what and certain zoom yeah
I felt a tremendous amount of pressure
and a tremendous amount of sort of after
how lonely and in some ways how
miserable sometimes the job got because
I just I just had to do more every month
I had to do more otherwise someone's
gonna catch me
mmm hard at the top isn't that I'm sure
I was getting violent are they great way
to talk about big yeah I had to go find
help
definitely what do you mean because I
didn't think it was sustainable I didn't
think it was very healthy really so what
was what has been impacted them when
your personal relations been yeah
everything yeah I'd be I'd be grumpy I'd
be would you get almost yeah if it's all
the stuff that I never had before about
this fear of what was someone else gonna
do if I if I did 30k in the month what
if someone did 31 you know even when I
was a might even when I was I never ever
sell it so when I was at that top I
stopped celebrating all the wins because
I I was worried they weren't gonna be
enough Wow
how did you start getting over that then
yeah so I went I went to work and I said
right you know this is this is a problem
my problem I've got you know I I need
someone who I can get either go and
chase or fine let's find something so to
get me out of this and and they were
great at the drop of a hat they said
well let's go find you a coach and so we
went externally and we found we found
someone who I knew I then sort of spent
some time talking it all through and
what did they help how did that help
jemaine's in some ways just having a
having a chat to someone who wasn't who
who I didn't feel like vulnerable with
because somebody very like completely I
put a huge amount of responsibility on
myself because of where I wanted people
to think who I was so I didn't dare
admit that that I wasn't that I wasn't
invincible so having someone who I could
chat chat that through and being
frightened you these the guy the guy was
fantastic but he he didn't have any you
know magic dust to pour over this yeah
yeah but he was he was someone who who
listened to what I've got and just and
gave me a bit of sort of pretty sort of
simple advice and you go away and you
implement it and enough it goes against
who someone sort of and I got I got the
love back
really if someone sort of fill in those
feelings and experience in some of those
things that maybe you experience there
what are some of the things that you'd
sort of tell them to start thinking
about so I think it's it's you've got to
get back back in that mindset whereby
you're chasing something because I think
if you're trying to do not know God yet
having that's the most important word is
that I think targets work for businesses
but goals work for P and not just your
revenue go like your own personal girl
definitely so every year now I and I say
I say now I've done this ever since I've
started is I'll write a write a wish
list yeah something and it's and it's
material stuff it's something I want to
buy or something I want to go and learn
and do at the start of each year and I
just put a little target next to it and
it's often it's a financial target or
it's a bit you know beat this you know
beat this record or something like that
and then every time I do it I'll go
treat myself with that yeah and so that
at the end of the year if I don't hit
this sort of notional target that
someone else might have dreamed up for
me or maybe I've dreamed that for me I
still know I've had a good year because
I've ticked off maybe those things that
start here which I thought were
aspirational mmm so them was part of
that was part of that process actually
making the time to give yourself a pat
on the back and celebrate some of the
things you've worked hard for and yeah
yeah definitely cause if you I think if
you even even the small stuff if you
don't celebrate it then you you know you
overlook it really quickly and our minds
a wonderful thing but it you know you've
you forget about all those all those
small wins if you think your whole year
rests on hitting hitting one target it's
really interesting
they staking me a bit took me quite a
long time to and now and that's really
helped you again it's really interesting
isn't it I think that's such a great
story so I think thank you for being so
open and honest because I think like so
many so many people a lot of people who
were listening and in recruitment will
want to get to that top spot but how
many people then at the top talk about
how actually they may not like it like
you're saying like why would you then
share with people like oh I'm actually
finding it really hard at the top
because all the things that you're
sharing you know I mean how many people
didn't actually talk about when they get
to the top there yeah this is actually
really hard I'm putting a lot of
pressure on myself for these things so I
think that's that's really interesting
I love interested in what what are some
of the things now again you you sort of
hand
exposure to people that you're chasing
and inspire you like what are some of
the things you've all seen than these
people that leave you sore so the people
there are performing even better than
these types of things like what are some
of the things you're picking up from
these people they may be you've
implemented or seen or found interesting
and if in their yes it's like what
lessons do think yeah yeah well just
because again now as you said you're
you're not in this top spot now and
there's people and you quite like that
because now you can look at people wow
they're there achieving this by my blood
but other knows anything you picked up
on it could be anyone it doesn't always
have to be because they make billing
more than you but is anything that
you've always that you've picked up on
over the last couple years that have
left you sort of inspired and you've
you've then utilized yourself for yeah
do you know this might come as really
disappointing users there isn't some
think that these guys are doing that is
revolutionary different to what anyone
does I think that's great to hear though
well I hope but hopefully I mean I I
find it inspiring to think that that
it's it's it's not it's not because
someone's landed a great big account or
they've been given something or they do
they do something I haven't got it it's
it's down it's down to relationships and
it's it's down to the subtle sort of
changes in how you how you think about
something so coming back to you know my
big point about business film is part of
everything we do is that so often people
think that a client is ism is a hot ism
sort of winning work is about getting a
job on yeah and they keep going back to
that same person in that organization
back and forth and thinking that rightly
because they give me regular jobs I've
nailed that client yeah and actually
what you don't realize is that
organization is made up of tens hundreds
thousands of people doing exactly the
same with lots of other recruiters and
if and if you can find a way then to
just you know to take that success story
in one fraction that business and start
to multiply it that's what I that's what
I think where it gets really successful
because suddenly you're not having to
start from scratch every time yeah
you've got someone internally who's
who's willing to say this guy is great
and actually we all love doing that
yeah if we've had great service we love
telling our friends about it because yet
dating your they they'll thank us for it
it's it's actually quite natural to be
it you know to want to be able to to
help our colleagues out but you've as
the recruiter you've you've got a
channel there and you've got to make
that work yeah and I think that's such a
great point I think so the episode with
James he spoke a lot about this how for
him once he's made the first placement
that's when the fun starts for him that
isn't where we're end so I think that's
a great that you're sort of sharing it
from your own perspective and sort of
what you've picked up on I guess what is
a typical day like they look like for
you I feel like it would be regimented
what what what would you make sure what
a non-negotiable is in your day and I'm
sure people would love to know what that
looks like what's it what is a typical
day that like for you on your billion
days yeah
so my billet my officially my my my last
billing day was the 31st of March last
year okay but then and and now I'm not a
big planner really oh yeah well I feel
like you would have been yeah I'm not
great at planning really and because
what I but what I what I do know is if I
think about something if I want to go do
it I've got to do it straightaway
yeah because our the forget about it or
inevitably you know you'll think I need
to call that client and if I forget
about it guarantee I call them the next
day in a bit ah if I need to call me
yesterday Nick yeah so yeah so what I
tend to tend to do is you know I am I
think I might try and with a high degree
of urgency I just get as much done in
the days as I can yeah but what I do
have is therefore golden rule whereby
there's always one thing I have to do
that day and I'll do that first get out
of the way because often sometimes this
about the hardest not perceived harder
yes sometimes it's the stuff you really
not a lot to do away and then everything
in the rest the day is downhill Ben yeah
so when quipment must have changed a lot
since you've been in the game what do
you think has been the biggest changes
so I've worked in really small setups
and learn and now quite a big company
yeah I there's probably there's aspects
of agreement I haven't changed at all
yeah and things like Tech LinkedIn so
LinkedIn you know sort of
after I started in recruitment so yeah
LinkedIn's definitely had a had a major
impact and it's probably her big
businesses and helped very small
businesses because suddenly that's a
real leveling fact everyone's got the
same database that's fair and increasing
increasingly so I think now I'm now
learning about content and ways in which
to sort of to reach your marketplace so
I think probably the recruiter now has
to be a lot more agile and has to be far
more open to different ways of working I
think I'm a process recruiter I think
I've got you I've got these set rules
and we're which I work you know for each
whether it's whether I'm working with a
candidate or or a client that's I I'll
go I'll follow that process and I'll
make sure I'll make sure I nailed that
but I'm trying I'm trying to improve my
understanding on on some of the softer
stuff yeah and how easy you find an app
because I think again typically someone
in your shoes have been written for a
while you've got those tools why would
lie it nah I know how it works like I'm
gonna kind of undoing what I doing that
no works do you not I mean why where's
the motivation behind that out of
interest because I think again that's
great to have that mindset but there may
be a lot of people listening who what
knife why wouldn't I know I need to do I
think and how have you found it have you
found going through that journey I think
that's why I enjoy yeah you and I had a
quick chat in weber about before and you
asked me what what I what I don't like
hmm and I if I hear you or someone on
your your podcast and then yeah and they
say you know when I try to make out like
you know recruitments easy or the
process is easy not good science yeah
because I don't want someone to sort of
belittle my I chose a career I don't
want someone to tell me my job's easy
because I find it really hard yeah are
going man and this thing it's the it's
the how the actual process of do you not
I mean that's what people say though
when they say that but you how much do
you bill in your first year 24 como so
how easy is recruitment how easy is the
person I'd tell you go you mean I think
but that's why people say that though do
you know I mean that's why people say
it's like well let the process doesn't
change
but yeah I know I know so what I suppose
when you asked me sort of how am i
finding it and I think it's what I'm
finding it is that's that's what gives
me the enjoyment hmm no I don't believe
although I've been you know I've had
this yeah I've been a recruitment
consultant for 13 years I don't believe
for a second that I've been doing the
same job I think every year it changes
and every year I've got to learn
something different so whether it's
about sort of the the psychology of an
interview or whether it's digital
marketing or or whether it's something
within within my market yeah if I don't
keep on top of that yeah dinosaur died
out so how do you see the next 5 10
years planning out what were you what
yeah how are you thinking about that in
terms of recruitment wise I'm pretty
comfortable about that right yeah I am
really am because the tech I think is is
a is an enabler for sure I don't believe
for a second ik it could it could
replace and you know what what I think
really good recruiters are are best
known for and and so I think you know
how much will it change next 5-10 years
I'm not sure sure
I think people the people who who either
have really low sort of engagement with
their clients who are these sort of CV
farms they probably need to be pretty
worried yeah but the people who are who
are spending the time to get some of
those those clients build up really
really strong relationships will find
that you know Tekel enables them to
handle the really low value work and
give them more time to do what they're
really good at yeah so I think it can
only get better do you think do you have
you always viewed recruitment as your
career I
I love recruitment yeah and it's
probably the tower it's probably it's
probably taken me quite a long time to
admit that really yeah
so Ives of what comes with calling
yourself a recruiter yeah so I call
myself a recruitment consultants yeah
and I didn't do that for quite a few
years I'd call myself a headhunter or
yeah a talent manager talent is the best
this is a perception because what I
thought was the perception yeah yeah
because I didn't think it was cool or I
didn't think I didn't think it was well
respect right well maybe yeah maybe
doesn't think it maybe doing
maybe I didn't think it was a career hmm
I think that's changing this there's
only one way it's gonna change is if
recruitment consultants change it hmm we
can't we can't expect other people to
award us you know a professional badge
or accreditation if we if we're
embarrassed about saying what we do yeah
so I think that yeah this is this is why
I started I think you are doing an
amazing job being this this this
champion for so many people and bringing
out these stories about people who are
really successful what what they do yeah
because we should be really proud of it
and and now looking looking back I can't
I mean I've seen it wasn't it wasn't a
strategy or a plan to get into into
recruitment but I I'm incredibly
grateful for it it's given me so much
and it's and the great thing is it still
does this I've got so much to learn and
so much I'm really excited about about
developing yeah and that I don't know
anything any other job that could do
that
mmm so um 2020 yeah was that little luck
for you may so I've got this new job
I've nice so since 1st of April my title
change from director to partnership
director what does that mean so there's
there was something that over the past
two to three years I've been sort of
perfecting and it's it's about sort of
taking the traditional sub contingency
model and there and then having a quick
look in terms of how how we apply that
and the we've patched it up internally
us as partnership ok and what we do what
we do is we get you know we'll go go to
a client and say right we do met look it
look at our numbers in in this
department you know listen to listen to
that line manager why can't we apply
this to every department you've got ok
and we build up a partnership and you
know with that without without boring
you too much this essentially it the way
it works is with we're still charging on
a fee for hire basis but what we will do
is if you instructors you're asking us
to spend X X amount of hours on it so
there'll be a bill it doesn't matter if
you hire your next-door neighbor or the
guy sat in the seat to the left of it
already but if you're asking is to
provide our services then there's a
there's a fee to be paid mmm how's that
been going on like it like anything this
it's there's lots of people who are used
to recruitment in its own ways
so there's lots of there's lots rats in
it and having a certain exchange and
there's lots there's lots of people who
are very comforting through recruiters
time for free so to those guys no it
wouldn't it doesn't go down very well
because it suddenly to them it they
think it's gonna be really expensive
because they put they manage recruiters
time really badly but there's lots and
lots of clients who've seen the benefit
to it and it the great thing for me is
it gives us having that sort of
certainty of billable hours means we can
do so much more for them and I think and
I think oh yeah we've now got a really
solid you do then obviously showcase on
a monthly basis like what you've done it
means it can means we do the wonderful
things through statistics about sort of
their their process from how many
Seavey's did we provide and people they
showed we can then show them the
feedback in these beautiful sort of
tables and this is what you know this is
what the market thinks of you when we've
gone out to their journey to this is
where no this is what they think about
you when they've when they've been
inside now this is the time that you've
spent to make decisions we can make we
probably need to make some tweaks here
you know and through to once our closest
relationship so we still see them once a
month and for some of them sat on the
board as a nominal position and we're
giving them updates on recruitment and
HR and those those are our most
successful relationships
yeah because seen as a partner yeah yeah
that's awesome and that's been a process
and journey since April no so that's
been about three years in the making
that's been my the thing that I've been
sort of most passionate about but then
having you know that admitted something
it's the the things that I wasn't
enjoying my management and then finding
these two guys who can then co-head the
two years set up as then meant I've got
a lot more time to do it and the other
good thing is it was a big career
milestone for me that I that I wanted to
go from I'd so I'd been this consultant
I'd got that management in that
management team but there was this there
was I was never on the board and and so
the first of April then that can die I
got my my board seat how'd that feel
that was phenomenal
that's because it and it's just
something I want I really really want it
and there was there's something about
you I think you asked
about sort of had how do people sort of
get on and how do they how do they
develop yeah and I think you've got a
bit you've got to be really proactive
you could ask for it yeah I asked for
that two years ago and - it's the chief
exec and and I'm not I don't know
whether he was being polite or not but
you know he you know he said let's have
a chat about it and there's no doubt I
was not ready for that in a slightest
but because I put my head I sort of my
hat in the ring and sort of marked out
my seat there for the future and I know
we agreed and what I needed to go do and
learn about before I was eligible to
join it and you know after that period
of time then we've got and the great
thing is personally is that I'm now sat
you know in an organisation that I feel
really passionate about alongside people
who used to be my managers who used to
the people who I looked up up to when I
first sort of started but now you know
we're now setting the same the same
table making some really bold decisions
and it's exciting yeah I think I think
that's such great advice I think because
a lot of people can really fall into the
trap of light now they're just it's just
a lot point the finger baton and be like
yeah then they're not give me any
opportunity like no I don't like them
it's not fair bla bla bla but as you
Coralie said I think in my experience
when I've worked for businesses and
stuff it's like yeah ask put your hat in
the ring and then if you do get pushback
it's like right ok what have I got to do
to get to a point where I can get to
where I want to yeah so I think that's
such great advice for those that are
wanting to push on and have more of an
impact in the business that they've
given a lot of time to it's like let
them know what that's what you want
instead of sitting there and moaning
when you get homes are there they're not
give me that opportunity blah blah blah
right cool so last question it's gone
quick on that yeah so normally I excited
about stuff but I think you sort of give
a a great just shared with us sort of
what's exciting I think there so look
what the last question I was asked is is
simple and that's if you if you could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there they'd listen to your advice
they take it on and implement it
tomorrow could be a phrase a sentence
what comes to mind what you want to tell
the people okay so it probably comes
back to sort of
development and they that one word is
proximity okay so no matter what type of
recruiter you think you are you know
whether you whether you like me being
processed or whether you're you know
you're more hisham about about sort of
social content and things what you have
to think about is your even your best
and closest client relationships they
will still succumb to competition if
you're not close enough to them hmm so
the idea here is that you know you have
to make sure you are in closest
proximity to your clients at any one
time and the challenges is is how you do
that this sort of Route one is a CV
isn't it just reminding your clients
this is what I do this is what I've got
to offer but that gets old really really
quickly and then you've got my trick
about ring names for advice about about
jobs but then you've got things like
industry events you know not only to
returning up but maybe maybe you float
them the cost of a ticket and you really
want them to be involved and I'm in real
estate so every month we go out to go
see a client's new building and we ask
them to volunteer their time for an hour
and we'll take ten or twelve people with
us to go learn about what they do and we
don't mention recruitment mm yeah we're
interested in what they're doing and how
it works but that's that's twelve
one-hour slots every year that we get to
spend with these guys one on one on one
learning about it and then and then you
there's there's lots of other sort of
ways you know ways we can be really
clever about about getting in time with
that clients but that's that's the key
is about if you're thinking about
building your desk or or improving your
kicking on and then it I think you've
got it you've got to find really clever
ways to be as close to your market as
close to your clients as possible and if
you're not you're leaving the door wide
open for someone who's more eager who's
willing to put in a bit harder graph
than you are mmm Nick's been a pleasure
thank you mate I enjoyed that more than
salt